Answering the question of where am I when you're at sea is not so easy, but luckily
you'll only need to know two pieces of information.
The first is latitude and may be you remember from Unit 1 that lines and latitude run parallel
and this 0° line of latitude is known as the equator.
The second piece of information we need is longitude.
The lines of longitude run from north to south and since they run this way,
they actually tells us our position east to west.
Now it turns out that one of these is very difficult to find and the one is very simple.
And let me give you a hint, you have used may be in one of the previous units
an effective method of calculating one of these--are the latitude or longitude.
Can you tell me which one?